Riverdale town without a zip code how
are you guys gonna be putting a modern
twist on such a classic iconic comic
books well luckily that wasn't my job
that was what Roberto aguirre-sacasa has
done so well and he just you know in
maintaining the integrity of the
original characters but bringing them
with a lot of sophistication into the
21st century
they got 21st century problems they got
21st century relationship it's very
modern your character how does he
compare to other characters you've
played in the past you know I think on
some ways this this character is the
closest one to me that I've ever played
because he's a guy that loves his kid
what's the best thing for him and that's
really all he's about know what I'm
about
you're a great kid aren't you really get
out there have a good time what I'm so
excited about with Riverdale is I feel
like it's gonna introduce a brand new
generation to these classic characters
were you a comic fan did you read Archie
comments yes I did I've always been a
huge comic fan and well what happened
many times is when you would go to buy
like Luke Cage or one of the you know
one of the other ones that you wanted
they would sell them in a three pack and
Archie would be in the middle right now
would always get the Archie I would read
that too and then after a while I found
myself looking for the arches I love all
these characters known him a long time
and these guys got a great take on
burning question Betty or Veronica
you'd have to flip a coin I mean you
they're getting ready you can write a
meet both them and you'll see what I
mean you would have to flip a coin when
you were younger oh when I when I was
younger I can I it was it was a Veronica
thing when I was a kid
yeah I like Ronnie lives what can I say
tell me more I don't think I've been
more excited about a new show this is
gonna be awesome
how are you feeling right now what can
we expect in Riverdale I'm feeling
really good right now we just saw we
just got to see the pilot last week
honestly every day I was like a 14 year
old all over again I mean it was amazing
to see something that we had you know
we'd seen the script all oh sorry like
back in November and so to see it
finally in front of us it was like
surreal no it's not the arty that you
see in the comics hey alright so we're
reintroducing Archie to a brand new
generation talk to me about who you guys
are playing and how you're putting a new
twist on that classic character well
Veronica in the comics she's you know
the spoiled rich girl who just like does
what she wants and there's definitely
that element to her in the pilot but
she's also Veronica's trying to be a
good girl in the show and she's
struggling with that inner conflict so I
think people are gonna appreciate that
and judge you by that right here I think
we all know who your plays yeah I'm
playing Archie Andrews and I guess after
the summer he comes back to school but
more buff probably attracted attracting
girls that he probably wasn't attracting
before and he's just got he's got a lot
of options after the summer I think we
see him struggling to as a as a kid you
know decide make some decisions and into
a man turning into a man talk to me girl
I'm Betty Cooper gosh Betty is the kind
forgiving girl next door but you know in
this new modern CW revival of Riverdale
she is struggling with her perfect
little image and she you know there's
cracks on the surface of all of these
characters and
unlike the comic books you get to see
the dark side of these character which
makes the whole show it has a darker
tone and a darker mood then who was
fangirling over Luke Perry being cast in
your show literally the nicest human
being you could ever meet in your life
and that's not it's like it's current
he's the dad on set he really feels like
like he just brings us all in and always
is giving us the best advice we're so
lucky to have him he's been through it
all so I mean we just oh he's amazing we
got to talk yeah we do you're stepping
into some of the most iconic comic book
shoes ever
Blaine Jughead fan favorite to joke
heads really the fan favorite I'm
honored I am when you were auditioning
for this role what was going through
your mind when I was auditioning for
this role sweat anxiety tears long
nights alone with a tub of ice cream no
I I was right I didn't really know if I
wanted to get back into acting and it
kind of fell into my lap and was such an
iconic character I feel like I'm really
hitting the ground running again as as
fast as possible so I'm excited I I come
from a pretty big comic-book background
myself I used to work at meltdown over
in Hollywood it's a huge comic shop so I
uh I was a little nervous representing a
comic book character is touchy because I
know when the comic books I love get
messed around with and media I get
incendiary quick I wanted to make sure I
was doing the right thing I wanted to
make sure I was appealing to the actual
fans of the comic series but it's a lot
it's a lot to take in
I'm excited though I think I think we
really hit a good place with this
Jughead
all right and what can we expect from
Riverdale 15 seconds on the clock are
you ready set go
old Archie comic book adaptation we're
changing we're trying to make it a
little more modern a little more gritty
we're taking off a series within the
actual digests in which Jughead was a
kind of sleuth a detective it's more
mysterious now we're definitely taking
off that mystery narrative from some of
the Archie comics but we're keeping the
fundamental teen drama basis the love
triangle all that
Jughead still sardonic sarcastic he's
that kind of character so we're trying
to keep it new fresh while dealing with
characters that are from the 40s and 50s
so nailed it awesome
[Music]